My name is Bryan.
I'm 20 years old.
I live in Los Angeles.
I'm a musician.
I play in bands around L.A.
We had a pretty good year.
Last year, we did a full US with Paramore.
We do this thing where we'll all split up and explore whatever city we're in.
While we're there, we'll take pictures of like,...
...if there's a little miniature gnome or just some weird statue.
We'll literally just take a picture of that and send it in a group text...
...so everyone else in the band would be like, "Oh look, it's Bryan!"...
...or "Oh look, it's Lucas!"
It's just like, we mess with each other that way,...
..."Oh look, I found you!"...
...and "It's a statue of some naked little angel baby or something."
Yeah, at least.
There's time for fun with the ladies.
Yeah.